all right Jamal I'll make one please be
with you how you guys doing welcome back
to the D show if you have not subscribed
subscribe right now hit the notification
bell so you can get all the latest shows
sent to you did you guys see that video
that went viral that kid Jamal who was
in school you send your kid to school
you go to school to learn and then he
ends up getting bullied ends up getting
traumatized well that's why I have my
next guest here we're going to be
touching upon this he is the new
champion at brave Kombat Federation yes
brother Abdul Karim how are you how you
been great great everything's been good
so far let's go ahead and we'll get
right into it let's watch this video and
we'll kick it off from there of young
Jamal who was just recently bullied I
mean this is like I mean just
traumatized with his broken arm yeah
what now for the people that haven't
seen it and we'll kick it off from there
how's that alright
what's your reaction when you see
something like that what's the first
thing that goes to your mind because you
deal you deal you actually contribute to
help in bully prevention huh you know
first thing the first reaction I get is
like I get disgusted you know you know
how could this happen how could people
be doing this and then at the same time
it also gives me a more motivation to to
try to spread out more awareness try to
teach more kids about self-defense so
things like this wouldn't happen anymore
I felt like if more kids had the
confidence they had the self-defense to
to be able to defend themselves under
such situations we would have less um
you know you know think things like this
going on we got to spend a little bit of
time together you're right you're
actually you just wanted this belt I got
this big belt here for everybody to see
this is from the what is this the brave
combat federation yeah
yeah so we got to spend a little bit
time together we had some nice training
and we went over some self-defense moves
and yeah so those those techniques were
actually very great techniques um we
also worked some specific techniques
from the video we just saw like the
positions Jamal was in things that you
know he could have done and then other
than that we also went over some other
techniques that would just you know more
for self-defense just different
positions different techniques and I
think they're they're very they're very
good and they helped a lot for people to
to work on those techniques that we just
showed what concerns me is that it's
nowadays you have this climate that's
been created you know a lot of this
manufactured fear of Islam and Muslims
when I say manufactured like because
it's kind of if you compare it to when
you go to if someone goes to the movies
they watch them on TV and those film
flicks are meant to scare you a horror
movie right that's manufactured right
it's not real they're manufacturing
something to scare you so
there's a deliberate attempt by some
people and then also people who are
ignorant about Islam never met a Muslim
or whatnot and now that's I call it
manufactured fear because really you had
nothing to fear of Islam you have
nothing to fear of our brother abdul
kareem from eddie from the deen show you
know until you've made that connection
you've looked into islam to see what
it's about you've met a muslim you've
interacted but then you have someone
who's also who've done who's done a
despicable thing this person at the
school but that person also becoming a
victim by many of these hate mongers and
people who are out there pumping pumping
these kids up and then they go and bully
and commit a criminal crime terrorize a
young innocent kid like jamal yeah 100%
like what you said it's all manufactured
like the people out there that you know
they're they're against islam and they
think of islam i was like i hate
religion to me really they're just
ignorant they don't know the truth like
it's impossible for them to know the
truth and still think the same i'm
pretty sure they don't have any Muslim
neighbors or any Muslim friends because
if they did honestly if a Muslim family
moved next door to you you would be the
happiest person in the world first of
all the chances of your kids getting in
trouble just went way down
okay went way down because the Muslim
community has the lowest crime rate the
highest entrepreneurship the highest
educational attainment for women in the
country they are the model American
community they would see the truth a lot
of my friends you know after a while
they open up and say you know I really
didn't expect this you know when I first
knew you were Muslim I kind of kept my
distance but you know after more being
closer with you training with you even
they're like we got to see like the true
image and I feel like it's a
responsibility for us Muslims also here
Muslims in America too to show exactly
what our original religion is about and
it's about peace so you know the more
people start to see the more they get to
learn and they'll know the truth but
then you have like I don't know some
media the movies or all that they they
give you that manufactured lies of like
how you know this religion is it's a
hate
and extremists and all that stuff and
then they have like some certain group
that does something crazy then it it
just did a stereotype for the whole
religion but I I see in my eyes the more
you know our fellow Americans get to
meet Muslims the more they get to love
their religion more and just some they
see this the the peace and love so
you've actually you've had situations
where you have friends who now have
gotten effective because I mean you just
can't help sometimes if you know I turn
on Fox News or I'd watch it you know
just to kind of feel you know the feel
feel what's out there was being said and
sometimes you just get your stomach
starts to turn right then I can imagine
someone else who gets affected by the
media and now you develop this
trepidation this fear and now fear will
cause you to do unreasonable
international things like like this kid
did against Jamal but then if I'm
understand it correctly so then you've
had some of these friends who hung out
with you and just connected with you and
then they've totally had a shift yeah
yeah so I never really experienced like
a hate type of situation but after a
while when you know we just get open
they're like by the way you know when we
first met it kind of kept my distance
but now you know knowing you and just
knowing more about your your life and
your religion you know I think it's nice
and they want to know more about the
culture that want to know more about the
religion and and I think like I said
it's a responsibility for me especially
like being on an MMA fighter and having
a big platform to to represent you know
Islam more and to show people really
what it's about because just like how
the media is is attacking you need to
defend and show what it is you know I'm
not saying show anything else show
exactly what their religion is which is
peace and love and I feel like it's a
big responsibility to show that and to
to share it with everyone else you know
be it your friends your Muslim friends
your non-muslim friends just strangers
you know a simple smile so
welcome peace be upon you you know all
of that is is a great step to move
forward now we went over some technical
things that Jamal if he was equipped he
could have he could have done we went
over the person grabs your neck and we
drilled that and then some other
variations of that you know how to take
the person down if someone throws a
punch we went over all these different
aspects so that kind of really shows
that because this is martial art
specifically what we were going over
developed by the Gracie family and they
as it be gone with someone Helio who was
much smaller and able to fight off much
a much bigger guy so that's one one of
the advantages that if somebody is
equipped there to defend themselves but
how would you now and I don't think they
would have stepped up to you now right
and it usually Jamal he's much smaller
and whatnot but how would you how would
you in this situation like how would you
handle the situation if you saw or what
not what wouldn't what would you so for
me um since I was a kid I would always
you know stand for the weak you know and
and it was really bad not only because
of the bullying situation going on and
the water and the mouth and and stuff
but also you can see Jamal's hand um
broke his arm was broke his I was broken
I had a cast on so like like what what
could he really do you know and and and
that brought to my attention where it
bothered me were like you could hear the
kids around laughing you know like there
should have been kids around there to to
stand for him and to stop what's going
on you know even if you know he knew
self-defense you know we're not we're
not always saying always attacking as
the right is the right thing to do you
know but there was this should have also
been other people around like students
or kids that same age - at least defend
Jamal so you can tell it was like a
group thing it wasn't just a one-on-one
kid you know they had the kid filming
yeah the kid bullying you had the other
kids around laughing and just cheering
him on and yeah it's just very
disrespectful that's even more sad
exactly what you said that now if this
is going on that instead of egging them
on you know what I mean
everybody's sitting back and like
pumping him up and taking pictures and
videos that somebody doesn't step up and
say hold on you know to come to the
rescue not not necessarily have to beat
up this kid but this should come to pull
him to the side you know to stand up and
say you know enough don't do this to
step up for the person as being
obviously victimized oppressed right
here by the broken arm yeah right and I
heard that even his sister with hijab
that she was also I don't know if you we
didn't watch that but his sister was
attacked also oh I didn't know that but
you see that's that that's really
disgusting you know and I'm not saying
because she's Muslim that it's good
anyway she's human any human yeah woman
like you know if it was either her hijab
or her hair you know just anyone that
doesn't wear a scarf and they just
pulled the hair that's that's very
disrespectful none of that should be
should be happening and I feel like it's
it's not only for the person itself to
have you know self-defense and to be
able to defend herself but also for the
people around you know there should
always be like a sense of cared you know
when you see something wrong you should
you know stand up and make sure to stop
it and always and always help the the
the week or the voiceless you know this
is something important especially and
this is why your contribution to this
because bullying is a huge epidemic I
really my hats go off to henna and henna
and his brother
who actually invited they invite here on
and henna who invited him to come out
and they helped to start a campaign I've
actually I know the buzz we've had one
of them here with us at our academy
we're good friends of the family
actually I was actually I was one of the
first reps for the Gracie fan that part
of the Gracie fandom and then we moved
on to Carlos Gracie jr. but I actually I
started with the torrents okay Academy
and then we were the first that opened
in Chicago our training center here so I
know the family that's one of my first
schooling comes from that particular
Academy so they invited him out to help
him so what I want to say is now yours
you you as a mixed martial artist you
have a louder voice and a bigger
responsibility because you guys are now
professional fighters someone else out
there the let's whatever name some of
the the big shots tyron woodley who else
someone who comes out and comes out to
my mind so been a scrimmage or since a
year or whatever you name it if more
people like that come out and to speak
out right because professional fighters
coming out and saying because people
around in this atmosphere thinking it's
cool but they come out and they set the
trance and that's not cool you know the
mean speaking out against it like you
are
you're more you're also more involved in
in the anti-bullying campaigns is that
right yes yes for sure um I started the
anti-bullying campaign about in the
beginning 2017 and it's something that's
been with me since I was a kid you know
when I was a kid I see bully you know
traumatizing another kid or something
I'd always hit that bully or like try to
stop him and that stayed with me up
until like high school you know like
what's physical like if I see someone
hit another another student someone less
less some strong or something I'd always
stand up for them and now when I when I
had this platform when I had um you know
being known as an MMA fighter I was able
to start my own program in Dallas Texas
for like anti-bullying and I found a lot
of success in that with like the local
kids you know boosting their confidence
if they're you know a bit weaker
character or disciplining the kid and
having having him more respected and
more discipline if he was like the more
aggressive type and energetic kid so we
had all types of categories of like the
characters that came in and each one
became had I had a better positive
effect through martial arts through
sports and you know I'm very proud of
this program and I had to pause it for a
while when I was in training camp for
for this last title fight but I'm going
to restart it right now in January
because it means a lot to me and it
makes me very proud like I said with
this platform I feel like it's a big
response
ability for me to give back to the
community and through one of the ways is
through this anti-bullying program
how does this work let's say a
professional fighter coming up comes up
that people look up to and then he
speaks out and he looks down upon and he
creates awareness that okay look if you
want to be tough I'm not saying or
advocating as people should jump in the
cage and fighting yeah what I'm saying
is that everyone now can go ahead and
get that that that that energy that they
have and learn a martial art right to be
able to defend themselves and if they
want to go and exhibit some kind of
force they can go do it in a healthy
competition yeah do it do it in a
productive manner rather than going and
bullying some kid on the street and
someone else like you come out so what
do you do actually when you come out and
you speak you know do you speak to high
schoolers college to these teens and
what exactly the message that you bring
across this so why don't you present you
brought up a really important point is I
try to have everyone enter you know
martial arts
you know everyone and I never tell them
like you know I want you to enter so you
could become a fighter and enter
competitions that's the last thing on my
mind like if you wanted to get into this
professionally and as your career that's
your choice that's like in the end but I
feel like everyone should enter martial
arts because the training you go to in
martial arts be it you know jiu-jitsu or
kickboxing whatever it is the training
you go to really describes life you know
you go through hard positions hard days
possibly maybe injuries
you know like diets so many things
happen in the martial arts world and
it's just like life you know you go
through crisis in life and then you
think it's the end of the world same
thing is in training you go you have a
really hard practice you think that's a
you know it's a bad day it's a you know
you're not you suck at this and then
later on you start seeing you know
you're becoming better the more pressure
you're getting from training is actually
making you better
the more pressure you're getting someone
you know maybe beating you up in
training it's actually making you
stronger and better and when you start
relating martial arts to life it really
helps you we always say like the hardest
thing is here in the gym when you go
back outside anything outside the door
it's so much easier um after you become
you know a martial artist so I always
promote martial arts to people as it's
gonna help them in their life no matter
what their situation is and for me I I
go to schools I go to you know companies
just for people like that need the
motivation they start lacking motivation
and get tired so I talked to people and
I I try to relate to them of what
they're doing to you know everyone else
is going through a struggle to fighting
everyone else has gone through a fight
mine might be a bit more physical but
everyone else is going through a certain
fight in their life and and then you go
back to the same you know pillars of how
to win this fight you know it's like the
the discipline and the concept
consistent work so I feel like you know
training martial arts and fighting is
all related to everyone everyone can
relate to that but in their own way if
it's studying you know you have to be
more consistent with your studying to
get to pass your exams if it's your work
you know you want to get a raise you
need to work hard in order to to get
that you know and I feel like training
martial arts can help everyone relate to
what they're looking for
do you see do you see other or a lack of
awareness created by other other people
who are in this profession do you see
more people speaking out against it so I
mean you know so not all martial artists
are the same you know some you know get
get really famous and they started
getting rich and they start you know
losing their ways you know just partying
and stuff and and some people are very
humble and very respectful like we have
a brother Habib no Magomedov he just won
the UFC belt like a month ago or so and
when he won he went to Nigeria and he
helped I think build a well or school
and you know you have some guys that
that always you know they do good the
more the more money they make the bigger
platform they get they use that to do
better and give back to the community
and I feel that's a big responsibility
other guys like I said you know
sometimes you know the
money and the fame gets in their way and
they just lose it but you know I don't I
don't really look at others I don't
really care about what other fighters
are doing I care about what I'm doing
and how much I can give back to the to
the people and be it talking be it
physical help or money or you know I I
try to do certain things with various
kinds of people from around the world
and I'm just I'm just trying to use this
platform to help more I think this is
really important because not discussing
like you know because they're obviously
there is there is the halal Haram aspect
of him and whatnot and I talked about
much on my show before you're already
involved in the sport right now you're
already involved in it and what I try to
do is motivate people just like you that
now you have you made a decision you're
an adult you're soundin adult you know
what you're doing okay you've wait
things out you're you've now Wanda's
belt okay yeah but at the end of the day
you know that the Creator the heavens on
earth does he really is this gonna is
gonna carry you tomorrow in the grave
and all the money that you make you
making millions now no but all that
stuff we're leaving it behind you're
gonna take all that tomorrow you start
writing nice cars and you know big homes
is that gonna go with you no it's a
tomorrow you know I try to motivate you
know and I'm sure your your you're also
the your brother-in-law he's one of my
friends Sheikh Omar right alongside him
and I'm sure you probably hear this a
lot from him but you know and others
that now you got you when people are
given this responsibilities platform
what are you gonna do with it now yeah I
mean are you gonna help make a
difference are you gonna help make a
change
you found me while others you know they
get over overexcited with the platform
and they use it for their own benefit
but they don't give back yeah yeah yeah
I mean when I first won this you know it
for a whole four I mean I've been
fighting for this for two years and a
half I can in this promotion winning
every fight undefeated in that promotion
just to get reach this and especially
the last four month of training camp and
that's all I was thinking about is
winning this but you know it felt good
the first day or two then now to me it's
just like you know metal with like
leather
you know it's it's not really worthless
but the reason I carry it around is
because the hope it gives the people I
see like you know little kids when they
see a bell you know their eyes glow and
oh wow you know world champion and I
want to be a world champion and and this
the things it does to other people you
know I'm still like showing it around to
like the little kids and doing these
little events and that's the reason I do
this you know like I said it's not
something like it's not a hobby right
now for me it's a responsibility I have
a lot of people looking up watching
every move I make so if I do something
good or something bad
there's a lot of people watching so I
make sure it's always something good
it's not something I'm doing because I
became a world champion it was always
there with me but like I said it's our
responsibility now because I'm on a
platform and there's a lot of eyes
watching to try to you know show the
image over the religion of just being
human as well like you know yeah I it's
not always hole or helping Muslims only
you know Martin or Muslims as well we do
food drives we do a lot of you know good
things just to people here in the USA
and it's just about also being human you
know good humans good Muslims and just
helping around that's there because I
said everyone has a message they're sure
they're saying someone else's message
copy caddy and passing another thing
negative setting netic negative trends
but setting good trends being good
examples and there's this powerful and
is different than the average layman
says it but when you have someone who
you mentioned your friend our brother
Habib when he mentioned in front of a
huge group of people then that obviously
you know the camera recorded and went
out to so many where he said he said
stay connected to God number one
important most important cross stay
connected when he got right strong
that's powerful right so now he went on
to say stay connected to prayer he would
always have to pray you always have to
stay on low in Spain
focus and stay connected together he
said keep it humble right where what do
you see usually if someone wins a belt
right win some money then the pride
kicks in the arrogance right ego you've
seen that of course of course and that's
that's what made him you know where he
is you know he's 27 you know undefeated
and that mentality he has where he wins
and then he always thinks back like all
thanks to Allah no an hundred Allah he
does so Jude he always says you know
this isn't because of me this is because
of God and and and that's what makes him
really really good you know because he's
very humble person he always gets back
in there like when you think about it
also like in the career-wise he always
gets back in the gym right after he
fights and he's just always looking to
improve and then religion why's he never
see him when big fights and just changed
the way he thinks or change his car
changes you know even even if you got a
new car there's nothing wrong with that
but I'm just saying the way he is he
just stays as he is as a as a good
humble person and I've met him
personally and before I met him
a lot of people I knew had met him and
everyone always had good things to say
about him they're like and the most word
they can always say is he's very humble
you know if you never watched him fight
if you never knew he was a fighter you
might you might not know that as well if
you just met him he's a very nice guy so
that's a very important thing that I I
feel like every fighter or person with a
plot platform should should have like
those characteristics of being humble
being nice and just always sending
positive vibes and messages you know
what the most important thing that
people also know that he's doing this
because what's teaching him to do this
yes his religion Islam that's what's
teaching him to be humble right
otherwise we'd be following our desires
and you know our egos but Islam is
what's keeping him in check
exact right that's keeping him humble
that's teaching him it's that's the
sponsor of these good
yeah and for yourself also right so when
we highlight that then people think like
wow I want to be like that now I want to
be like Mike yeah I want to be like who
he's following right he's following the
man who was sent you know just like
Jesus Moses and all the other messages
problem Hamid peace and blessings upon
them that's our example right that's the
person that we're emulating and this is
where we get our teachings found in
Islam so when people will start to
really think like wow this is
interesting I'm gonna look more into it
I'm gonna block out for now you know all
the light with the media and the Fox
News and all these other politicians and
others who are trying to divide us let
me go for myself and really look for it
objectively openly and let me see what's
really captivating these people and
having their lives keeping them humble
connected to God and all that you know
living this simple humble lies and who
knows what can happen from there yeah I
mean some people they're very selfish
you know they just want to have the
pleasure of you know the very fancy
lifestyle when they have the money in
fame you know the parties the cars the
trips whatever it is and then you have
other people like they feel they have
the pleasure of helping others you know
like when you when you do good when you
help someone out when you see someone
you know having a really bad day or
going through a problem and you help
them out and you see that happiness in
their eyes you really feel a pleasure
inside like you know you you feel like
you did something great but then you
never you know you're just trying to
live that fancy lifestyle really from
inside I know I know I know they're not
happy you know they sometimes they put
on the fake smiles the fake happiness
and and how much is that gonna last them
like a day or two a week but really when
you when you're really helping others in
so many various ways I'm not saying you
know donate all your money you know
there's so many ways you can help other
people is in Islam it says even as a
smile is a charity you know in just a
smile you say a smile someone Salam
alaikum just peace be upon you it's a
charity so like in so many ways you feel
good about yourself and that gives you
real meaning you know there's there's no
meaning I feel to life if you have like
millions and you're hated by others and
everyone's just jealous and envious of
your lifestyle and you
really able to really have a meaning in
your life I feel like that's not
something I want to do you know but you
know using the platform and even if you
don't have a plot saying just for the
people with a platform but even if you
don't have a platform you could you can
affect anyone you know you can affect
your family you can affect your friends
you can affect the work you go to the
school you go to like everyone has a
certain platform they can use a radius
of people around them of being on in
real life or in social media or in some
way that they can help spread the
message of Islam which is peace and love
and and I think that's a responsibility
everyone has yeah this is something that
you know when people see the commonality
I mean the love we have for Jesus you
know Islam simply meaning submission to
the will of the creator and not the
creation and every time I made some
videos talking about you know some of
the things that khabib says I'm when he
says alhamdulillah Allah raises to God
inshallah God willing and then it's not
so foreign to people people like yeah
wow that means peace be unto you right
alhamdulillah they're taking the Creator
it's kind of like hallelujah yeah hey so
when you when you bridge those those
gaps right it becomes less of the the
other people think oh that's you know
something different that's other but
when you when you define it into English
and people they can relate to it allahu
ekber right yeah almost that a war-cry
you know that's praising God God is the
greatest right greater than that money
greater than his belt greater than fame
anything you know that God is the
greatest you put your Creator first and
foremost how was your father he's great
my father he was one of the biggest
supports for me in this sport in life
his name Osama bata give him my Salaam
yeah yeah he is I will so he's been a
great support for me throughout my life
and then specifically throughout my
career you know when I first started he
was always there with me and the fights
so like we usually find on Friday so if
we were we fought locally in Jordan
he'll give the Friday football you know
like noontime and then that night we'll
be in the MMA cage you know fighting for
one of these big fights and we've done
that a lot and
so he's always there with me like either
cutting weight or training with me or
you know coming to all the intense
training sessions with me after the
fight you know when we do our programs
go to schools and you know he's just
always there so we were also known in
the beginning I was like a father-son
type of relationship of like fighting
and we always said this is a family
business you know
I bring my whole family into this
because it's not a hobby like I said
it's a it's my career and and everyone
has to be part of this in my family so
he was uh I would say we're 5050 you
know like if we would divide it like the
work and everything he's always there
and he's a big part of the success and
my first title I actually gave to him
and I was like you know this was your
dream and we made it happen so you know
I'm gonna give this to you
so he's been one of your great greatest
inspiration your father yeah greatest
inspirations and motivations since the
beginning you know now we know we've
been in this for like seven years so
he's always liked studying tape on my
opponents he holds pads for me we do
like our strength and conditioning
together and he lives in Jordan right
now so I I lived there for a while when
I was training we do everything together
now we only get to train each with each
other when I'm when I'm there visiting
does he visit over here at all no he
just he likes to stay there you know he
just live in the retired life he's just
enjoying his time training you know he
also teaches religion in English over
there in Jordan so he speaks fluent
English fluid English of course cuz he
was here for like we're in Baton Rouge
Louisiana for like 27 years yeah he
lives over here was an imam here for 27
years he was actually the Imam he was
actually the Sheikh for almost laymen oh
he was his share yeah yeah it was Asia
and then he moved to Jordan and he
became a teacher their religion and yeah
just enjoying he's just enjoying over
there he's there teaching religion he
trains right now and when I when I fight
you know we travel together and
we take care of business Sean ah yeah so
what what else your how was like a your
daily what does your day look like you
know when you how when you for me when
you wake up and now does Islam help to
make your day go by smoother because
obviously now Ramadan comes around
you're felt like Habib he says that
that's it when Ramadan comes I stop
everything I don't go into the you know
fight you know he doesn't go yeah he
takes a timeout because that's that
spiritual boot camp that we do right
along with the five pillars but how do
you incorporate with your prayers and
whatnot and select for me a regular day
would be like I'll wake up for Fechter
you know professor then go back to sleep
for like an hour hour and a half or so
and then I'd go to my strength and
conditioning training in the morning
after that I'll get some light grappling
in like just techniques cuz the strength
and conditioning would be very tough
I'll go back home you know have some
lunch pray the hood and then I'll go to
the mosque um I have a program over
there as well there's like a Quran
school like have school I'll do like PE
for them over there in the mosque so
it's called PE class but I've usable
education yeah it's called physical
education class but I give them martial
arts yeah because they enjoy it and I
feel like it's something they should
learn and just it's a more enjoyable way
to do physical education after that you
know I go back you know relax a bit pray
also prayer then I have my own program
going on the anti-bullying anti-bullying
training sessions for like the kids like
5 years old until like 11 after that
class I have a older class of men's
class those are like adults will do that
and then I'll go to the gym by that time
it's my head of prayer so I'll pray in
the gym you know everyone there's used
to me praying you know first they used
to talk to me while I was praying like
are you okay what's going on but now
they're all used to it I have my own
room
you know they're I over there and then I
start my MMA training it's about like
two hours and a half finished training
Preah you know sit with my teammates
maybe my coach you know have a good time
and then go home have have dinner and
repeat somebody hearing this maybe for
the first time they might be thinking
about us a lot of praying
you guys pray a lot yeah it's five times
a day five times a day but I usually
make the example I say well how many
times are you calling your wife to tell
her you love her
Yeah right the guys like you know I love
you baby or she's calling her man her
husband I love you and like maybe call
him 20 times a day and freyr's basically
a communication between you and Allah
between you and God so how many times do
you communicate with your friends like
you say how many how much time do we
spend on social media communicating with
other people you know sometimes random
people how many times you spend you know
on the social media or calling so it's
the same thing praying is a
communication between you and God so you
need to balance you know the
communication between you and the most
important between you and God which is
the most important communication and
then how much time do you spend with
these other communications you know yeah
right that's a good point you know
communicating with everyone else you
know you in the world but not taking you
take a time out to thank your Creator to
be grateful to show gratitude you know
and grateful people are happy people is
proven yeah so showing your gratitude
connecting with your Creator that's a
wonderful thing and it doesn't does it
get in the way no of course it doesn't
get away it's actually the total
opposite actually helps you know because
you know what when you pray you could
ask for anything and sometimes I pray
and I ask for you know to not be injured
in this next training session that's
gonna be very intense or I pray for the
strength so you know I so many things
you could pray for in your prayer
so I actually feel like it gives me a
positive boost and motivation to
continue throughout my day all the time
how much how much was Muhammad Ali have
you studied some of the life of Muhammad
I did and and I
I loved it a lot that the things he
would say like he had certain quotes I
wasn't able to really get into his life
details but like certain quotes he would
say certain videos you know the tributes
they made to him that you know like how
he would not fear any man except for
Allah you know as a fighter you know
you always have that thinking of you
know you're not scared of anyone but
then you have like there's only one
person you're afraid of and he's a
creator and just so many things the way
he carried himself out and at the same
time when they came to God he was very
humble but when it came to like you know
opponents he was um he was like uh like
type the the mentality type of like not
scared and like undefeated type of
mentality that's beautiful man a person
can can be busy can you you you schedule
you schedule your date around the prayer
like making sure that you don't miss
that because that's your lifeline
because a person can can have everything
and then they try to squeeze in like
that they try to squeeze in the salat
you know no no you make sure that
everything else gets squeezed in but
this is your priority right yeah so even
even when we were in the Middle East
sometimes there would be training
sessions where the salat time would come
during the training session they would
pause pause everyone goes miracle do and
we pray we pray during the training
session everyone stops and and that just
how it was that's how that's how
everything went
and then hamdullah you know it was it
was a great Brotherhood it was a great
Brotherhood and you know Salah was never
in the way he was always like just a
positive effect yeah many people don't
know that we pray like Jesus prayed you
know Jesus fell out his face and he
prayed to the Creator the same way we
pray we fall on her face and pray to God
and this is a strong connection when
people see that there's something about
the prayer when you stop and you pray
and then they're watching you like what
is he doing you know you're going to
show gratefulness you're taking the
highest part of man putting on the
lowest part in the ground you're
humbling yourself to your
creator there's no statue in front of
you you're not praying to a man to a
saint to anything in creation but to the
creator of creation and people observe
that they respect that when you're when
you're dedicated discipline and you
stand for something not just yourself
like you said earlier you're just
selfish it's just about me me me all
right no no and after after words its it
develops you that you're you're able to
give more and that shows a lot when
people see that you know have you ever
noticed that of you people observe you
ever your friends yes yes then I feel
like you know it could be a good thing
and it could be a bad thing like once
you're praying and you're showing
everyone you're praying you also need to
make sure that outside from praying
you're also a good person because you
can't just pray and they're like oh he's
praying and then you're a bad person you
treat everyone with disrespect and then
they start relating these two together
like oh he's praying so that means he's
religious and he's such a disrespectful
person so that must be part of his
religion you know so once you're praying
and you're showing everyone you're
praying you need to always represent the
peaceful and loving side of the religion
and so then they can make that positive
relationship of oh he's praying he's
religious he's a good person so that
means it's a religion of peace so I feel
like it's a big responsibility again
when you show everyone what the religion
is and you're praying you need to always
give back and be positive peaceful and
loving I remind people that if the the
prayer the fasting the charity the Hajj
all these things these are rituals but
these rituals are supposed to help
develop you to become better these are
the things that we do that are supposed
to help us to become better human beings
yes and if they're not making I mean
we're off we're gonna fall short we all
make mistakes we're not perfect but
these things we go back to to help us
you know these are this these are the
things without these things it's very
difficult you know to rise to your full
potential and this helps us to get to
that I like how you made that connection
where the Deen is not just okay you go
into the mustard you pray now you left
as they say you left the law you love
God in the must you mean when you go out
and you're ripping people off you're
lying you're deceiving and then is
worthless
exact
we exactly um and you know like I said
it's a responsibility you know and it
should be in your character it should be
just like who you are as a person and
like me talking about myself like I feel
like you know just talking about the
religion and praying and just being good
I'm not perfect myself you know I make
many mistakes just like how I'm a
regular human being but one thing is I
try you know I try my best and and and
that's that's just me you know I'm not
gonna sit here and just say like yeah
I'm perfect and I pray and I'm just the
best person every to every person I see
you know you know no I I try my best you
know and and like I said you know
especially with um with the platform I
have you know I'm gonna try my best to
always give back to the people
how's your nutrition and how point is
that it's very good do you know um I
would like to eat like what are some of
the things that you because the fuel
that's a few yeah so for me I try to
keep my nutrition very clean very
natural very healthy I try to keep it as
my lifestyle not as crash diets yeah
where I just died it really hard for
like three weeks or two weeks and then I
just destroy that so you know I do still
have some on and off times where like
you know I'm eating more clean cleaner
than other times and it's really just
about the same food I'm eating just
different amounts of like less
vegetables more vegetables more proteins
as proteins but I'm really like a big
fan of the less ingredients the more
natural ingredients type of foods you
know when you start reading labels and
there's names you can't even pronounce I
try to avoid those as much as possible
just really the basic foods like it's
funny how people always call talking
about the newly developed diet the
scientific and all that but really if
you want the healthiest diet you go to
like the older days like you know like
more of like you know just the basic of
like vegetables proteins even
carbohydrates but all the natural
sources but once you start going to like
come
made foods processed foods and just like
chemicals and all that that that's what
really you know it gets tricky you start
having bad metabolism and and all these
sicknesses cancer if I don't know like I
just try to stay as natural and healthy
as possible yeah we call that so
avoiding the term it the fake foods yeah
faith foods a sugar like the bad sugars
I don't want to say sugars because then
you have like honey and like the dates
that's sugars but that's really healthy
sugars you know that's real food that's
real food
yeah real food but then you have like
other like these processed type of food
I call it fake food you know and it's
not about the calories always not about
the proteins so you have these
sweeteners zero sugar zero calories but
that stuff is not good for you either
now it's good you know so just you know
not really looking at the calories but
I'm really looking at the health
benefits of what you're eating is really
good like not even on the same leave
meat and just become vegetarian like
there's real food out there like real
cow meat real chicken but then you have
like some companies you know when you
get the items they're they're they're
cheaper items or just more processed you
know fake foods avoid that yeah that's
the key to health yeah I mean I've
taught me we've been talking about this
for some time now that people are
distinguishing what's real what's fake
but you said it right there when you
start reading ingredients that you can't
pronounce you need a PhD right in
chemistry to go ahead and figure this
out that's probably fake food leave it
alone but just eating the food that the
Creator has given us you know real food
doesn't come with a list of ingredients
that you can't pronounce yeah yeah yeah
I mean frosty have you always been like
that where you've always like been
cautious what you eat or or when you got
into the sport so I mean I've I've I
went into like the the phase of like the
processed foods but like the healthy
processed foods were like oh instead of
eating a banana you can eat this type of
protein bar and you'll get this and this
and this and this and then I saw like
there's a lot of processed ingredients
in them
so right now sometimes if I would eat
like a certain energy bar or a protein
bar it would be really made from like
just natural ingredients of like dates
nuts how do you like the shake I made
you that shake was actually really good
and speaking of the ingredients one of
them would actually get you thinking
that it wouldn't taste good which was
the eggs uh-huh so the raw eggs and the
shake now get you thinking that it's not
going to taste good but drinking the
shake and knowing after I mean for me I
don't really mind the rise is the G fry
eggs but I mean what most people for
other people that just get that reaction
of you know it's it's not something they
would drink but I'm always down to try
new things but it was it was a good
shake they actually did a there was a
documentary I think it was called sugar
or forgot the name of it but what
specifically this person did was like
you mentioned a healthy healthy
processed you know candy bars and hell
under the term healthy he just ate that
there was another guy who obviously we
know about that he just ate the
processed fast foods McDonald's and then
then they followed him and how his
health deteriorated but this guy in this
document he just ate the healthy food
that's out the yogurts and almost full
of sugar you know full of chemicals just
that and then he went from being healthy
to really unhealthy Wow and it's showing
the gimmick behind it yeah yeah I mean I
feel like when it comes to these these
diets and these food items it's all
about business in the end you know
anything that someone's trying to sell
you I told my friends any ones trying to
sell you something like a diet or trying
to sell you something really fancy like
oh try this and avoid this type of food
and don't do it it's always like a fade
just just to get you to pay money go
down to the basics like in the Quran
everything mentioned and local Don right
now through science it's known as the
superfood
like when we're talking about dates
honey
figs those are all super foods you know
olives now everyone's talking about like
the
Oh dye and high fats you know this is
all mentioned in the Quran about you
know each each food over there and I'm
talking about natural organic all this
type is is what you should be on you
know yeah now of course just like how
I'm not perfect my diet isn't perfect
either but that would that would be like
the best diet it's just natural organic
really I thought about real organic even
when you go to the market and it says
organic it doesn't always mean like it's
organic as you would think you know when
I used to live in Jordan that was kind
of organic when we would actually raise
our own food crops there you go you know
we'd have chickens and we'd eat the eggs
and and there's a big difference in the
taste from between that and the organic
eggs and the non-organic eggs so I mean
not everyone can eat everything they
grow yes you know but if you can that
that's that's actually really good so
that's what I try to push off the people
real simple that's like white Bell level
eat real food
avoid fake food rules yeah eat real food
avoid the fake food yeah even if you
can't do it 100%
there's always levels to it you know
like fried food avoiding fried food that
can in fast-food restaurants or or
something you know avoiding the high
processed sugars that's I would say that
would be one of the most important steps
is avoiding the high processed foods be
it sugar or like chips or like
everything high prot like high process
so you could tell like you could start
by steps I'm not saying change your
lifestyle 180 degrees in one day but
like slowly gradually doing it so it can
become a lifestyle not a crash diet
exact if you can get it up to 70 80 %
somewhere there that you're eating
clearly like yeah you weren't working up
slowly like I sell to white belt in
Bluebell yeah yeah movin up eating out
and restaurants you know it changed the
type of food you eating you know instead
of like maybe fried chicken and fries
get like a good salad or you know yeah a
chicken salad or something like you know
and then and then you start eating more
home foods
I love eating home foods more than more
than restaurants really keeping it
balanced
yeah absolutely that's where actually
that's a step of all because when you go
when you eat out in these foods that the
MSG and then the extra sugar the so all
of the the ingredients to excite the
tastebuds but at the end of the day it
comes at a cause but when you're at home
that's one and you can go ahead and
monitor what you're putting into the
exact that's a step above eating at home
yeah yeah yeah so I really had a great
time hanging out with you need to as
well
inshallah we have you back God willing
and Charlotte again I'm the Dean show
give salams
to your brother-in-law and also to your
father I will have you back again
sometime thank you God bless you jack
salaam aleikum to set up and thank you
guys for tuning in sudden good trends
being a good example what also we cover
staying connected to your Creator to God
keeping it humble keeping a respectful
these are the kind of things that are
positive and these are the kind of
things that need to be highlighted and
pushed out of a message that resonates
with the good inside all of us so set
good trends do good things and
insha'Allah we'll have you here back on
the Deen show subscribe if you haven't
already hit the notification bell every
week new show we'll see you next time
inshallah until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum
this is malik who my brother habib alex
ah how are you sir hamdullah what's the
number one most important thing for you
and should be for everyone Habib number
one important most important for us stay
connect with the God you always have to
pray you always want to stay humble and
stay focused and stay connected together
what else you want to say Habib for the
Dean Shaw audience
with our guard we cannot do nothing
everything is nothing you know number
one we live on your one God Thank You
hubby this was fun
nice having you but we're looking
forward to having you on the real show
the Dean show what do you say brother
let's do it just send me location thank
you so much guys